hey guys it's Thursday January 7th I'm
Mary and you're watching GameSpot news
Christmas might be over but destinies
new year gifts arrived today as
announced previously all destiny players
are getting gifts of 15 strange coins
and 15 motes of light today because
you're all so awesome bungee Road on its
website oh shut up go on the gift should
already be there and you can get them
through your in-game postmaster you'll
want to make sure you have enough space
to accept the gifts bungees first weekly
update of 2016 is expected to arrive
this afternoon at which time more
details will become available even more
gifts are coming to destiny players to
everyone who logs into destiny and
completes any playable activity between
January 7th and January 10 will receive
a special emblem this is a fancy secret
emblem which will be delivered to all
qualifying players on January 12th but
we don't know anything else about it yes
next up the Xbox one system update hits
a day but you probably didn't even
notice Microsoft has released a new Xbox
one system update but don't expect any
new features
Larry Major Nelson wrote on Twitter that
the update includes fixes for some
unspecified behind-the-scenes bugs
there's no patch notes so we don't
really know what they're doing back
there besides fixing some mystery stuff
Microsoft didn't release a big new Xbox
one update in December and isn't
planning one for January
that's because Microsoft wants to focus
on stability you know during the holiday
season the next major update is
scheduled for February but we don't know
it's gonna hold
lots of secret things going on at
Microsoft right now finally Minecraft
Pocket Edition 2 was released on Apple
Store and it's soared to the top of the
charts the problem it's a trap as
Eurogamer reports a game called
Minecraft Pocket Edition to was recently
released but it wasn't made by Mojang
and it isn't much of a game at all
despite that the $7 game which is the
same price as the genuine version race
to the top of the top grossing charts
reaching number 4 though it's since
fallen down Pocket Edition too
official description sounds good enough
saying players can explore randomly
generated worlds and build amazing
things in true Minecraft form the
description even contains a link to a
trailer for the real version of
Minecraft Pocket Edition Minecraft
Pocket Edition 2 is a terrible top-down
swipe game in which is omni's attacks
scorpion from Mortal Kombat the site
Road I bought it and spent a few minutes
playing it or crashed my iphone if it
isn't already obvious don't buy it the
creator is listed as Scott Cawthon which
is a misspelling of five nights at
Freddy's creator Scott coffin some other
games released by Cawthorne include what
appear to be illegitimate five nights at
Freddy's and Mortal Kombat games
currently Minecraft Pocket Edition 2 is
available but Mojang is hoping that it
won't be there much longer it's great
that minecraft has inspired people to
create amazing things but when a product
attempts to dupe our community or
exploit their enthusiasm to the game
it's our responsibility to step in
Mojang's
Owen Hill told Eurogamer our dedicated
enforcement team are extremely busy
here's hoping scott cawthon is removed
from the Apple Store sued and left in a
ditch somewhere and that's all the news
I have for you today but I'll see you
again tomorrow for our top 5 stories of
the week see then